we now know pretty well what the track
of this balloon was it started in China
uh using prevailing winds but also with
some capacity to maneuver itself it came
close to the Aleutian Islands over
Alaska through Canada into the United
States and then it hovered it hovered
over the missile Fields the ICBM missile
fields in Montana where the Americans
keep their Minutemen 3 strategic nuclear
missiles
um and we know also that this this
balloon has since maneuvered so it can
move itself both up and down to catch
different air currents and left and
right so it's not completely random it's
a pretty big thing too these balloons
are fairly large and this balloon is
always being measured according to the
proverbial three buses the three London
buses and in fact the the three buses
refers to the the width of the balloon
and the width of the gondola underneath
the bloom which is where all the solar
panels are and the intelligence
gathering equipment but it's the size of
these things that makes them quite
interesting and quite difficult to shoot
down in August 1998 the British Canadian
and American Air Force has failed to
shoot down a rogue meteorological
balloon that was over the Arctic and was
a threat to civilian air traffic and
they couldn't get it down the Canadians
pumped uh over a thousand Cannon shells
into the thing and it still put lots of
holes in it did not deflate it enough to
bring it down so they're not as easy to
shoot down as people imagine and they're
not as as combustible as people imagine
the other thing that's interesting about
this is the question of the altitude the
the the height at which it was moving it
was moving at about sixty thousand feet
now the heights that are normally uh
considered important are civilian Earth
traffic that goes about between Thirty
and forty thousand feet not many
civilian Airlines ever go above 40 000
feet Jets fighter jets they tend to go
at 50 000 feet they can go to fifty
thousand feet I have to say they don't
perform terribly well above 40 000 feet
because the air is too thin so most
aircraft are well below 50 000 feet most
of the time balloons begin at sixty
thousand feet and most of them go up to
about a hundred and fifty thousand so
this balloon was at the at the base of
the normal altitude that balloons
operator which of course tells us that
the Chinese knew it would be spotted
good grief you can see the thing from
the ground just with the naked eye so
they knew it would be spotted this was
it's clearly a surveillance balloon it
was clearly going to be seen this is a
military stunt which they're pulling
because they want to react to What
America is doing elsewhere in the world
and particularly in the towards the
South China Sea in the Philippines
it's gone wrong on them it's become a
causal labor of something else it's
pointed out to the rest of the world
that they do this that they that they
invade other people's airspace that
they're looking at people all the time
they've done it to other countries
they've been over Hawaii they've been
over Guam in the past this is a stunt
which has sort of gone wrong and the
Americans actually are getting more out
of it by milking it showing that this is
what China gets up to and so probably
what seemed like a good idea in Beijing
last week is something they've lost
control of it probably doesn't seem such
a good idea this week